are you ready for some Mass Effect
Andromeda multiplayer the beta might
have been cancelled but we've still got
some new info I'm Tony this is a game
spot news update and for all the latest
on bioware's spacefaring adventure be
sure to subscribe Mass Effect Andromeda
will receive multiplayer expansions
after launch assumedly with new maps
characters and gear each time but the
best part is that it'll all be totally
free the lack of any season pass for the
game probably made a few of you scratch
your heads but a dlc like this is going
to be free it doesn't really matter it's
just a shame the technical test had to
get canceled I know you all really
wanted to give the new more mobile
multiplayer ago at least Andromeda is
launching soon you can grab it on ps4
xbox one or PC on march 21st if you want
to fire some guns on earth in the
meantime you can check out our review in
progress for Ghost Recon wildlands right
now and for all the latest space game
news you're already in the right place
you
[Music]